Jordan greenhalgh how are you today I'm
doing well apparently on the other side
of the pond I will be Greenhalgh forever
your name your name is it flip-flops
between the two right which which one
are you now I am Jordan Hall Jordan Hall
yeah Jordan Hall I was I was born Jordan
Hall yeah I changed my name when I got
married to green Hall yeah um and I am
now back to Jordan Hall okay
but everyone is now updated also for the
viewers who are watching on YouTube you
will notice that I am now in HD video
guy Dean my video producer forced me to
get a better webcam before it was a
potato sticking out the front of there
one disadvantage is that now I I because
it was so pixelated before I could get
away with not doing my hair I could get
away with like you know put wearing
essentially pajamas and no no pants or
whatever I wanted whereas now I have to
make it a little bit more of an effort
which is good for the guests I suppose
and also that the viewers at home so
Jordan what have you been working on
recently so I would like to compliment
you on your HD I noticed that when I was
looking at it it's like wow that is very
crisp that's some sharp imagery right
now yeah it is okay so let's see well if
I'll assume a certain degree of
familiarity with what I've been up to
because otherwise the story ends up
being pretty long but the the basic
premise is for the past 20 years or so
I've been trying to get a sense of what
we might say is sort of the fundamental
nature of the game that we've found
ourselves playing for some significant
period of time but I'll call game a and
initially really grabbing it from a
bunch of different threads and just
noticing that if you just kept pulling
the thread say for example the thread of
the 2008 financial crisis and then the
2010 echo in Europe if you take that
thread you just keep following it and
just keep asking the question of what's
under this what's deeper what's D
what's deeper there's a way to find
yourself at a very deep level that shows
that in fact as far as I can tell there
has been a particularly been playing
together since the birth of agricultural
civilization that were still essentially
playing out that game as you'd mentioned
that there was a game before that that
was pre the birth of agricultural
civilization and the sort of the
transition between the two was a big
part of the early story and that from my
perspective it became more and more
clear of her time that that particular
game this game made this game of
agricultural civilization its most
current form has a certain trajectory to
it it has a certain set of call it
fundamental dynamics that lead to it
failing in certain ways and that it
reboots reforms tries to keep searching
for ways to keep going on its own but
there's a sort of a meta terminus is
that there's a game to end all games the
game of Thrones actually comes to an end
and we're sort of there we're at the end
of game a you know maybe in the next
year maybe in the next 20 years but
we're definitely at a point where the
the methodology by which that game is
able to reboot and try to re-establish
itself is coming to a to a terminus and
so in that context what I've been doing
most recently is what might mean we what
might we do in that context how do we
find a way to really step outside of the
game
because if we're in the game at all
we're kind of in the game all the way
it's a very tricky thing so is their way
to step outside of that game completely
and to almost discover or maybe also in
some sense remember a new game that is
simultaneously something that we can't
that is not going to be a next release
all terminating and is really responsive
to this situation that we actually find
ourselves in and is able to be born in
the context of now
while still developed and develop on its
own terms into being able to essentially
take over from game a in the time that
we have so what that's it
what briefly characterizes game a the is
that the question that takes 20 minutes
or 20 hours should I say if you were to
briefly which is probably about three
hours we could do that briefly in about
three hours my guess understood but the
current status quo is what you're
talking about
and moving forward and trying to find
something which doesn't have a terminus
that ends up with us all being destroyed
sure let me let me try to see if I can
do it briefly it's always fun to do
things in real time and see what lands
Fisher has it forces forces you to
actually push your agency if anything
comes out the way we're going so one way
of thinking about it is trying to figure
out how to get human beings to live
together relatively peaceably using
formal institutional structures that's a
nice way to summarize it so any
variation on that theme which I would
just call society so I'll define society
as human beings being in relationship
with each other at least meaningfully
mediated by formal institutional
structures yeah I think based on what
I've read of your work I think that's
you've managed to do it there you go
that's three hours three hours condensed
into 30 seconds congratulation
graduations month and if that makes
sense to you then we're okay cool we
actually did compress something and are
now in a place that's it's uh it's
actually very powerful to be able to do
that if it didn't make sense to you
the suggestion might be you know there's
a lot behind it and we could continue to
explore that and open it up I understand
so you've mentioned that there is a
threat of some kind sounds quite
existential that's at the end of this
particular iteration of society that
we're rolling through at the moment
mm-hmm why is that inevitable
okay this is fun again trying to
compress something that is fast this
one's actually harder to do in a way
that actually makes I think makes sense
but let me let me begin let's see if I
can say this well so you might say that
gaming is fundamentally characterized as
a rival risk game it's able to perceive
and relate to this other thing that I've
called the anti rival wrist but it's
fundamentally a rival wrist game which
is to say that it's fundamentally win
lose at the end it is very very bottom
it addresses the question of when push
comes to shove when you're pushing me
which of us loses so it has all kinds of
different solutions to how do we avoid
killing each other how do we try to
actually cooperate so that things get
better but at it's very center like the
fundamental code of game a is we're
playing a rival wrist game and I think
this is actually relatively selling it
now like many people are feeling the oh
wait a minute the other guys are
fighting to win how do I make sure that
I I where there's no more sort of
playing together how do we make sure the
other guys don't win and that and it
because it is so fundamentally that way
what we notice is that through many
different paths by the way there's at
least three that we've been able to
identify our best efforts to weave
something together that actually holds
us together as a some larger community
in peace unravel in the fullness of time
which you know sometimes takes a
thousand years sometimes it takes fifty
years just depends on circumstances so
one example and you mentioned this in
the in the pre before we started filming
is I think very salient like it people
can grasp like feel this very well which
is the the circumstance that we found
ourself in right at the tail end of
World War two what
the things that happens in rivalries
game something is premise done reverse
games is that violence ends up being the
checksum at the end of the day when push
comes to shove we're pushing and shoving
meaning that we are in fact using
violence and the one who actually wins
is the one who's better at fighting war
has been always the last move in the
game and so the last big war that we had
World War 2 was really bad right lots of
bad things happened and lots of really
significant kinds of violence were
unleashed in the world but what we
noticed was the very last move in that
game caused everybody to have to go whoa
because when atomic energy was
discovered and used and then
ever-so-slightly evolved we went from
the a-bomb to the h-bomb and we went
from the h-bomb in just american hands
to the h-bomb in at least two people's
hands it was suddenly entered into the
collective consciousness that we were in
a compareed different place that as bad
as world war ii was up until the moment
of multipolar nuclear power
we couldn't [ __ ] it up too badly we
couldn't kill everybody didn't try as we
want with bullets and bombs humanity was
going to continue to sort of move
forward we could reboot from World War
two and say okay wow that suck let's try
a better thing and in fact did but by
the mid 50s it was clear that we had now
invented a way to kill everybody or at
least to so catastrophic Lee create
violence as to make the notion of there
being and next after that quite
questionable I believe it was Einstein
who said I don't know how would War
three is going to be fought the world
were for when we fought with sticks and
stones at the proposition that the depth
of that reboot reboot is really deep
yeah okay great well that was scary and
for a long time people were like wow
this is you know all of our history has
told us that we were going to get into
fights so for a whole generation even
two generations my generation the sense
was particular Holocaust is inevitable
and tomorrow
you know we had nuclear bomb drill
when I was in school in elementary
school like he would actually get him to
your desk put a book over your shoulders
and pretend that would help you survive
and you could rip off and that weighed
heavily on the zeitgeist by the way and
a lot of what's going on right now
connect should be traced back to the
psychological consequences of growing up
in that kind of an environment
particularly the boomers the hangover
very long hangover from that the long
and deep hangover so okay that's that
but what we discovered when the wall
came down was that in the context of
nuclear war while catastrophic and
fragile it did actually the end of the
day only require that two men two
specific men in this case Reagan and
Gorbachev not push a button which is
okay if either them push the button we
all die but as long as both of them
simply manage not to push the button
we're okay and we managed to pull that
off as such when you talk about it like
that it makes the a well obviously the
line is very very fine but you were
aware just how fine it is when it's your
your two buttons button presses away the
one button pipes press away we get on
one side yeah you totally right but it
either if either one pushes the button
the game's over but we managed not to do
that
so okay neat now we can trace that and
notice that it's not just two now now
nuclear proliferation is right at the
edge like we know for example that say
Israel in South Africa our nuclear
powers there's no question along with
the UK in France Germany Pakistan India
but when I spent time for example with
people who were the experts in nuclear
proliferation and they're sending a
message saying hey we're not gonna be
able to hold back to the dam forever
that we are going to be experiencing
nuclear events over the next couple of
decades because as our technical prowess
continues to advance the distance
between being nuclear and being
non-nuclear gets smaller and smaller and
particular at the fall the Soviet Union
the proliferation of both nuclear
capacity and physical material out into
places like use Becca Stan the capacity
to hold back that wall became less and
less
so that's challenging but then what
happens this is that you do you abstract
you go up with at will and say okay the
challenge isn't really nuclear war the
challenge is the ability to deploy
destructive power in a fashion that is
fundamentally catastrophic to human
civilization at all
okay well nuclear power is a first
example of that capacity but as our
technical capability increases both by
the way in terms of our capacity to
destroy and in terms of the fragility of
the civilization upon which we depend
right so now for example as we as we
begin to make smart grids as our
electrical power system is dependent on
computational capacity and as our
fundamental infrastructure say our water
systems are dependent upon electrical
capacity as we've moved from you know
men going out and turning gears to
robots actuated and robots actuated
connected to computers cyber war moves
from a very silly thing that a bunch of
script kiddies might do to make your
email send you funny messages to killing
everyone and that's it is continuing to
be the case that we are building levels
of fragility into the fabric of our
civilization or construct because we
need to because we need to have
continuing use of the power that it
gives us but it also makes us more and
more vulnerable think back to the
financial crisis as we became more and
more dependent on increasingly
complicated instruments of finance it
generated at least for a while a feeling
of economic expansion but at the cost of
fragility and so on the one hand our
continuing exploration of technical
sophistication and utilization of that
builds a level of increased wealth and
experience of quality of life but at the
cost of fragility and on the other hand
we keep finding really cool ways to kill
everybody like steak crisper it used to
be that only really the Soviet Union and
the United States had the capacity to
engineer meaning leaf
new biological organisms that could do
danger with the invention of CRISPR like
a single movement from science of from
one place to another just like nuclear
weapons from pre-atomic to post atomic
the bar has been dropped tremendously
and there's every reason to believe that
we're gonna kind of follow a Moore's law
of destructive potential where more and
more capacity will become more and more
distributed so eventually your your
blender in your kitchen will be able to
blow up the world and no 10 adequately
motivated smart high school kids yeah
maybe like that's a and in it's funny
like you think really an Ikea like 10
adequate and motivated smart high school
kids right now could meaningfully
disrupt the entire global financial
industry right now no plot no question
right for sure
and in some sense already have like the
hacking of Sony for example yeah and the
hacking of Experian we're probably in
that range like they probably were not
CIA
they may have been but they probably
weren't they probably were just
meaningfully intelligent and not yea and
bored exactly and maybe a little bit
like angst-ridden like you know
angst-ridden teenagers can kill us all
should send a chill than everyone's spot
and then what happens is right so now
with the last piece now connect the dots
so I've got a game which at the end of
the day is fundamentally rival risk and
in many ways every time we've
experienced a long piece like the ones
from world war ii nür now it's largely
been because caddis like decisive
strategic advantage in military the
capacity to deploy violence has been
held by one or maybe two players as for
the stability of bipolar superpower 'dom
the Soviet Union the United States
played a big role that because everyone
else was vastly inferior to the United
States and the Soviet Union's ability to
deploy violence it really did mean that
kind of two grown-ups could kind of keep
things relatively peaceful on a global
basis or we had the thinking of the long
piece of the British Empire and etc etc
but when we find ourselves in a
multipolar
I'm stance which is what in fact we were
clearly entering into an even tri-polar
just the decline of the American
hegemony and the opening up and see the
Chinese trying to establish themselves
you end up in a situation where the game
theoretic choice making of players
around escalating capacity to deploy or
protect from violence leads to an
escalation technical capability pretty
straightforward right I mean if this is
the missile gap the missile gap story
continues to be true it's easy to say
well we need to spend a trillion dollars
in American defense because the Chinese
are spending a trillion dollars in
defense and they're gonna obsolete our
aircraft carriers in two years so we
have to have a response so we have to
innovate a new way but of course they
then look at that and say well they have
to in a bit a new way and so we fight we
force each other to go into an
innovation conflict which means that we
must continue to push the curve on the
capacity to innovate new and
sophisticated ways to kill everybody
it's dick-measuring on the grandest and
most destructive scale possible right
and with if you include the loopback of
actually being able to what are those
things called you know penis enlargement
yeah
if penis enlargement really worked
imagine what the consequences would
actually be this is exactly the problem
it's exactly that there's no I honestly
think that if penis enlargement was more
decentralized that we may have greater
problems than someone pushing the button
it would be well it would just be
catastrophe everywhere it would be it's
fine if we could actually explore many
of the things that are happening at the
cultural level is actually that is
posturing and dick-measuring isn't it
yeah you told me right I John I think
you've managed to in the space of just
under 20 minutes there you've managed to
give a great synopsis so we are at
there's it's actually deeper principles
there's more fundamental stuff but this
is a good like the gives you a sense
you're at least they're like you can
handle you're holding one like piece of
the story that's like okay that's that's
for sure there there's like two or three
deeper principles but we don't need to
go there this scenes been set so where
do we go from here or why do we go from
there from that that point of the story
moving forward what and and also I'm
sure you'll get into it
be right well that's where we go so like
the first step is to recognize you have
a problem you know hi my name is Jordan
I play game a we need to get there we
need to get there rapidly and
collectively and let's take for example
what happened in 2016 in America in the
States you guys had it a few about a
year earlier right we keep being handed
wonderful opportunities to recognize
that we have a problem and we keep
finding increasingly sophisticated ways
to deny that we have a problem we need
to notice we have a problem and we need
to take the time to really perceive that
and really take it as our problem like
not their problem not some pick your
poison and yeah you know point point the
things you're in and create the
appropriate disparagement that fits your
particular perspective on these things
yep nope no it's in fact my problem I'm
going to take full responsibility for
where we are which means by the way
understanding what it means to take
responsibility I can't be an activist
because activism is false responsibility
it's expecting that you can do stuff you
can't actually do what can you take
responsibility for well the first thing
you can take responsibility for is
participating at all in the kind of mind
what I call a sense maker the kind of
sense maker that is game a at the game a
sense maker is a kind it's not the only
one that exists in potential there are
other examples but it's the generator
function if you always find yourself
trying to figure out how to solve
problems from the game a toolkit using
the game a sense maker then all you're
doing is playing game a now that turns
out to be daunting and for a lot of
people the game the sort of the story
stops there although to be perfectly
frank for the vast majority of people it
actually wouldn't be that hard to shift
but because of the way the human beings
will relate to each other it ends up
being how do I said is right
most people look to other people to
figure out what the right way to respond
to the world is we're a mimetic creature
right we're mimetic creature right so
it's the sort the kind of people who for
whatever remember that remember see that
big great photograph of like a Nuremberg
style rally and there's like a hundred
thousand Nazis like saluting and one
dude standing there folding his arms
even see it oh it's great you should get
it and like you put it up yep because
the question the point is if you had ten
people fold in their arms the whole
rally falls apart because the end of the
day people are like signal like feeling
out into their environment okay what is
the right way to respond to what's
happening and if they're just getting
signals that are also pointing in the
same direction that okay I guess that's
what it is but there are some people who
for whatever reason because of their
life experience because of their
genotype because of secure circumstance
are in a position to not respond in the
self-reinforcing feedback loop of their
social milieu if there's enough of them
that are signaling something different
and they're signalling that something
different with some coherence meaning
that it's kind of showing up is the same
kind of signal then you begin to get a
shift and it gives everybody else an
orientation towards what right action
might feel like it might look like so
that's how you begin to make the move
from game a 2-game P is that first step
sorry to interject that it sounds an
awful lot like the manifestation of game
a is just an extrapolation of the way
that we naturally are were tribal
creatures with this rival risk game
would have been played out
surely in nomadic tribes a long time ago
you're in this valley you see someone
from another valley therefore there is
some conflict between the two of you it
is an extrapolation of that activated by
the invention of formalized structure
right so there was a long time where we
interacted with each other what you
might call the trap
that is actually not game a it's
something pre yeah and there may be many
many flavors without is hard for me to
know you know deep anthropologists
probably have insight into that but once
you add actuation by formal structure
the invention of society the invention
of weight like law and money and the
ability to use learning to invent social
abstractions that can actuate human
collective intelligence this group is
groups of human who can coordinate in
ways that make them more effective in
the world then you're playing gaming I
understand my my concern wanting to move
towards something which is a more
long-term strategy was that game a was
simply our genetic code our tribal
nature but manifesting itself and that
moving from that to anything which isn't
that would be such a monumental task
that it would require us to go through a
new evolution yep yep fortunately this
evolution actually happened about
150,000 to 1.5 million years ago okay
this is really good news because if that
hadn't happened I agree with you that
the likelihood that we'd be able to sort
of undergo an evolution of that
magnitude in real time with the [ __ ]
hitting the fan is essentially zero so
this is what I mean when I say that
human beings are not the same as other
primates meaning like significantly
something happened and we're obviously
witnessing the consequences to that but
we can actually identify it now and dial
it back in so the story kind of goes
like this I'll try to keep it compact
because they don't have infinite time if
you take a look at other primates closed
primaries they say orangutangs
gorillas chimpanzees etc what you notice
in humans and in fact in this case all
social mammals you notice that they all
have access to a particular kind of
hierarchical structure particularly
among males we can call a dominance
hierarchy mmm this place it's gotten a
lot of traction over the past year
because of the other Jordan
so that's commonplace and we have that
so you might say our natural need to
compete with each other for a certain
kind of scarcity and to organize
ourselves into effective competing bands
is real that's a real part of our nature
we human beings also have and is the
thing that actually makes us human and
not other kinds of primates a different
way of doing things it's called a
prestige hierarchy which is odd because
it's not really a hierarchy but it's
called a prestige dynamic so we've got
the dominance dynamic which is a
hierarchy and the prestige dynamic other
primates don't have the prestige dynamic
this is a incomprehensibly fundamental
thing so it's worth sort of actually
slowing down chimpanzees do not do a
very good job of learning from each
other if a particular champion Z has
discovered something neato it doesn't
spread through the through the band or
the troupe this is because dominance
hierarchies are premise taun mostly
physical violence so a dominant male is
able to beat the crap out of other males
and their force established himself as
dominant and he may have a small number
of beta buddies who kind of like get the
table scraps since to support him but
the big thing there is the way that the
males relate to each other is largely a
version meaning you don't make eye
contact with the dominant male because
that means it's a threat he's gonna kick
your ass what's really [ __ ] hard to
learn things from other people if you
don't make eye contact with them yeah
right yep
human beings found themselves at over
what appears to have been a pretty darn
long exploration in evolutionary space
finding a way to take advantage of the
capacity of learning so to interject
that some of the listeners familiar with
previous episodes will know William von
Hippel who wrote the social leap it was
an explanation of how we went from
Australopithecus out onto the plains the
development of the throwing arm and all
of this were from one of the big
discoveries or one of the big claims
that he made was that
the anticipation of felt needs and
unwanted needs was a real a real key
element here so the fact that chimpanzee
creates a tool let's say simple tool for
poking at something creating some food
whatever it might be at the end of the
day it can't anticipate the fact that it
needs it again so it just throws it away
mmm and then the next day it comes back
it's got to make the tool again yep
however what the one of the the main
archeological finds which identified
this movement towards being able to
anticipate unfelt needs was that
multiple tools were being found in sites
where human ancestors had been so what
that meant was that not only had they
made them once and then thrown them away
they'd made them and then taken them
with them the next day so yeah that
anticipation and also you know
communication can't communicate and
especially if you can't make eye contact
but even if you you know you've got no
sophisticated language at all you're
totally right how does the the
collective consciousness grow it doesn't
it does it so there's a very large
number like 17 maybe more distinct
innovations that kind of have you ever
seen this like a Japanese puzzle that
has a bunch of different pieces where
you have to be able to actually be able
to twist pull and and slide all at once
in a very smooth relationship to get it
to move is this like just the world's
hottest rubik's cube kind of thing is
interesting is that if you pull it binds
on the twists if you if you slide it
binds on the pull right so you have to
actually get all this so evolution of
Homo sapiens sapiens was kind of like
that like you had to get you had to get
grandmother's which is a neat thing that
grandmother's that the notion that
females live long enough that a mother
has a daughter and is still alive long
enough to actually co-parent her
daughter's children is a big deal yeah
you had to get fatherhood like the
notion that males could have a lived
select
a Fitness adaptation by virtue of
putting their energy into attending to
the well-being of their actual
biological children isn't neat is an
innovation you had to have a capacity to
have anticipated needs you had to have a
capacity to enter into a relationship
long enough the communication had a
place to emerge and then you had to have
the development of the physiological and
neurological capacity to explore the
space of potential communication all
right so all of these pieces you have to
have all of them and they kind of like
slide against each other until it snaps
into this new thing that's our
legalistically in sapiens totally get it
that's a really lovely analogy to use
with the puzzle I think that makes that
makes complete sense it's wonderful
we're gonna pause for one second there
make the only thing is it keeps on I
think it might be my internet connection
it's gonna flick to another network I'll
cut this let me see if this holds on are
we back we're back we're back sweet so
we'll just go from here again man
right and I'll let you know I have I
have 15 minutes
that's fine and then and then a maybe a
little bit of time depending on when the
next folks show up totally fine let's
really I'm here so so what we find
ourselves is that this new thing which
is in fact the difference between Homo
sapiens and all other primates is this
new kind of relationship that we cut
that they call the prestige relationship
and in the prestige relationship what
happens is we discover the power of
learning and learning from each other so
learning is learning from each other
there's one kind where I go out in the
world now I experience the world
directly and I kind of figure stuff out
but when I am able to do what we're
doing right now I can take my entire
lifetime of work which is not easy and
convey to you a pretty sizable chunk of
it in an hour that's learning right that
is a significant shift in fact and so
everything that's happened since then is
a consequence of that [ __ ] like the
dynamic of that capacity the ability to
convert the
irreducible energetic and temporal
characteristic of being in the world
like the fact that it takes a whole
lifetime to turn a child into an adult
compress that into a shareable moment
that upgrades the quality of being in
the world much faster than that is where
we are right that's the whole point of
why humans are different and every
single moment since then is the
consequence of that played out in a wide
variety of different ways so that's the
good news that evolution already
happened we over the past 150 thousand
years have just been playing out the
consequences of those two dynamics in
relationship with each other right the
the dominance hierarchy has been around
for a real long time so in the beginning
humans would use learning to allow them
to achieve rival risk dominance with
other animals and plants in their local
environment and of course we very
quickly discovered that with a little
bit of learning vickicooper at the peak
predator anywhere so they could move
from the African savanna out into the
deserts into Islands up into the Arctic
and in the space of two or three
generations use learning using this this
capacity we just described to
out-compete all other animals in a rival
wrist way right and become the peak
predator well then what happened was we
expanded across the entire globe and
expanded in our population enough that
suddenly the thing that we ended up
running into is not animals but other
people well now we enter into the next
phase of the game we're still more or
less playing out the game of dominance
still more or less playing out the game
so deeply hardwired into our mmmm a lien
structure that is sort of still the
primary tone but we're continuing Lee
having to get better and better at
playing the prestige game in order to
win the dominance game as we saw right
the the explosion of civilization
explosion the Sumerians and the
Egyptians and just their expansion
against the tribal model is the use of
prestige under constraints that enslave
it fundamentally to dominance to allow
dominance to out-compete dominance was
in his game a now
just described gave me an even more
fundamental way and somewhere around
maybe World War two I kind of really
think of like the moment the the aha
moment that must have happened with
every single military leader during
World War two when they discovered that
sophisticated soldiers with you know
healthy vigorous and good tactics ended
up constantly getting out competed by
sort of a pencil neck geeks sitting F
bat back in Bletchley Park like whoa
[ __ ]
the smartypants are now actually the
decisive factor you know it doesn't
matter how many men I throw into the
field and how well-trained they are one
nuke takes them out there's the one of
you have a man with a button well as
long as you have a man who knows how to
make a better button then my buttons
bigger than your button so then you
entered into the game and this is a
thing I think their Weinstein has been
exploring I think not exploring aware of
this part of the story but exploring it
really deeply is you know the game from
1950 until now has been we'll shoot how
do I make sure that I keep how do I be
be in charge of the button while getting
other people to build me a better button
okay that's kind of where we are right
there yep we've got a whole bunch of
folks who are still really fundamentally
playing some variation of the dominance
game trying to figure out how to
continue to stay in charge to stay
dominant over prestige so we might say
that the shift that we're really talking
about is actually very simple we just
need to finish the story that happened a
million and a half years ago of fulfill
the shift from dominance to prestige
from Game a to game B to a game that is
crema stone the learning of learning
premise ston both the advantages that
happens when we're able to actually
communicate truth to each other and
learn from each other and the kinds of
relationships that we need to be in for
that to flourish what are the steps that
you think need to be taken to go from
game a to game be I'm aware that's a
grand question but today has been a day
of trying to get you to condense down
some very complicated topics into some
into some short short sentences of
sure I I think it's actually relatively
straightforward I think that it takes
there are 1 2 3 there are 4 steps it is
a 4 step program we've been able to
actually eliminate 8 we're getting more
efficient amazing so the first step is
to recognize and acknowledge that you
have a problem and to really let that
sink all the way down into your toes I
would call this entering into a
extraordinarily deep level of humility
and let that just dissolve and say okay
it's this is a bunch of good phrase it's
like sadly I don't have the right
language for this particular stage but
it is that extraordinary humility
surrender is another big one I allow
yourself to sink into a liminal space
into not knowing and know that the only
thing you can really know is you
definitely don't know and allow that
paradox that cowan which is actually
just a really nice description of
reality to sink in and dissolve and
settle step 1
the transition from step one to step 2
is choosing to then take full
responsibility for how it is that you're
actually going to show up in the world I
would call this reclaiming your
sovereignty I've described sovereignty
in other places so I won't go into too
much detail but sovereignty begins here
that is an effect in you it is your
capacity to take responsibility for the
choices that you make in the world to be
able to say I and I alone and solely
responsible for the choices that I make
and the first choice that I'm going to
make is the choice to get better at
making better choices and to proceed
from there okay and as you continue to
expand your we might call sphere of
sovereignty the space of life in which
you can in fact actually be responsible
you can't actually make good choices in
the context of what's actually happening
then you enter into the third step and
this I might call certain thing
right relationship and some portion that
is vocation by the way is it turns out I
actually outlined this portion of that
post that I talked about so it's this is
a nice loop close naturally so the right
relationship is from perspective from a
place of sovereignty
how'd you begin to show up in
relationship in a better way and of
course generally speaking this would
tend to be the first close relationships
but you might think of this as all old
relationships how do you enter into
relationship with nature how do you
introduce relationship with money how do
you enter into a relationship with time
right it's just all relationships can
you use sovereignty this is developing
and capacities to make better choices
and to sense what a better choice feels
like without having to use knowing
without having to use some prefab schema
of what the right choices is it's been
handed down to you by probably somebody
else's story do you build a capacity to
begin entering into right relationship
and I should mention by the way that
starting at the center like starting
with the people who you love is a really
good place to start this by the way will
uncork for anyone who's worried about a
feeling of meaning this is where the
feeling of meaning is most fully
revealed and an example might thereby
Pierce a thing that used to be called
vocation or are calling as you begin to
build sovereignty you will also be able
to fill in yourself that which is in
fact your calling what is your right
relationship with doing in the world as
opposed to some notion of like I ought
to do something or I have a duty to do
something or I can I can tell myself the
story that makes sense that I will do
something even though I hate it nope
what is your calling
what is your vocation doesn't of that
step and of course you can notice that
there's no a really positive loop that
adds you enter into more and more right
relationship with more and more of the
world this gives you more capacity to
build your own sovereignty you get help
from friends who will give you
evolutionary feedback that helps you get
more insight into where your sovereignty
can perhaps improve the domain of
competence has been expanded yes that's
right and and the in
banded from self to other expanded into
into into something like a wheat like a
team our family or friendship and of
course then as your sovereignty
increases your capacity to enter into a
relationship increases that's really
nice right so then we enter into the
final step and I would call that step
the step of coherence and this is may or
may not be a calling for people in any
meaningful time frame but for some
people it might be so this is where you
feel called your right relationship is
the calling to enter into a relationship
of collective sovereignty where there is
a feeling of connection to some other
people or person that was just one
oftentimes just one the dyad a partner
to so fully enter into relationship that
you actually learn how to enter into a
level of fluidity a level of honesty a
level of integrity together that has in
some sense its own kind of identity that
the synergistic relationship gives rise
to a wholeness that is greater than the
sum of the parts and is fully nurturing
to the continuing sovereignty of the
parts and we find this I think if we
really feel about a good partnership is
like I'm thinking here a marriage but it
doesn't have to be that you can think
and in fact I think it's just proper to
think that there are three different
entities there is the two humans and the
relationship are all real and that as
the humans enter into their sovereignty
and enter into skillfulness and
relationship the relationship itself
begins to have a capacity to nurture the
human beings and this is coherence and
this is very real and in the space of
coherence we are now playing game be
fully
to enter into larger and larger
relationships of coherence as that
domain begins to expand and expand and
include more people yep
but it needs to be taken slowly why well
our generation is still habitually
playing game at and so it's very easy to
fall into those old habits it's very
easy to strategize for example it's very
easy to run unconscious old code and how
we enter into relationship and I think
my dog is telling me our our
conversation is at an end and so that's
a great that's a fantastic way to call
like this is your two-minute warning
guys
we've yes it's we time and warp time
it's we determine what time and so um so
that's the story like that's I think is
it it seems very simple and compared to
like we're going to engineer a
decentralized economy on the bay right
but it is actually that simple and and
yet not at all easy I understand Jordan
thank you so much for your time I feel
we could have gone on for an awful lot
longer but as everyone knows the
sovereignty of the dog and also the we
time if the dog is very important so we
need to we need to let it go and and
have it to ease in its poos and can you
tell the listeners where they can find
you online please well up until this
last post the two places to find me were
on my medium channel once called deep
code that it was called evolving culture
I'm sorry I'm urgent coop Walter and on
my youtube channel but I'm not sure that
I'm going to continue writing or
creating videos so I suppose that I was
imagining it I will probably put a
breadcrumb of where I'll be next in
those locations but I suspect there will
fact be a new place in the next year or
so that's exciting that sounds that
sounds super super exciting I will be
following the breadcrumbs as I'm sure a
lot of listeners will be with with great
interest so thank you very much for your
time I really appreciate you coming on
my absolute pleasure thank you thank you
about
[Music]
you